reject thank you so much and thank you
for your patience you know everyone
loves computers right uh so again my
name is Jenna zeigen and i'll be talking
to you about what would happen if your
brain or literally javascript i'm going
to keep the suspense a little bit while
i introduce myself a little bit more so
i'm an engineering manager at digital
ocean and the manager of the front-end
team and you might know me as
eigenvector on twitter the Zygon puns
don't really go as far here but that's
cool and if you want to follow along on
your own computers or send these slice
to someone else you can find them at
jenna is / reject jay s alright so admit
the title of my talk is a little click
baby baby so our adventure today is
really going to be comparing bits of
human cognition to bits of JavaScript
the thing is humans know a lot more
about JavaScript than we know about
human cognition that's because humans
made JavaScript but really listen all
the stuff we know about human cognition
about how the mind works we really know
from just poking at the human mind with
experiments therefore we only really
have theories about how the human mind
works we know really nothing for
absolute certain there's also a lot of
different subcategories within cognitive
science and trying to cover all of these
things and compare them also javascript
in 30 minutes would be a little bonkers
uh but also a lot of this is irrelevant
right javascript doesn't perceive it
doesn't make judgments on its own and
it's not conscious and let's hope
javascript never becomes conscious right
but there were a few of these ven I saw
that had potential to compare to
JavaScript so I chose three of them and
those are what we'll be covering
day so first and perhaps most obviously
we'll talk about human language as it
compares to programming languages
secondly we'll talk about human concepts
and categories of versus javascripts
prototypes and primitives and thirdly
human attention versus the JavaScript
event loop so the most obvious
comparison is comparing javascript to
human language so there's a pretty
obvious difference in here right which
is that javascript is a programming
language it's synthetic and human
languages are mostly natural languages
so being that javascript is a
programming language and that is it is
since synthetic it has a lot more
regulation than natural languages so for
JavaScript we have tc39 this standards
body who passed specs hold discussions
on certain things I don't really know
what else they do to be honest but they
help JavaScript stay in line and keep
evolving so because of that JavaScript
also evolves a lot faster than human
languages human languages evolve but
it's it's pretty slowly it happens over
hundreds of years and the evolution is
mainly you know we bring in words from
other languages and slaying gets like
kind of more officially in language you
know that moment when on fleek is going
to be in the dictionary um so yeah so
this happens of like slower then how
JavaScript of JavaScript evolves like
you might have felt like a taker took a
really long time to past es6 / 2015 spec
but that was pretty short as compared to
natural languages despite all of this
change though human languages are a lot
harder to learn than programming
languages so you know to become
proficient at a human language takes
years and years and years and it gets
harder and harder as you age after a
certain point when you're really little
called the critical period when you're
kind of like meant to be learning new
languages well with programming
languages i'm willing to bet that the
vast majority of us learned her to
program or are learning how to program
as adults
so another big difference that I see
between programming languages and
natural languages that I think is really
cool is that programming languages
create and manipulate the programming
environment rather than just describe it
so its language itself that is making
these changes to the environment it's
mutating state it's making new objects
but we don't really can't really do this
with natural languages I can't say we're
not like wizard Harry Potter I can't say
Akio chocolate bar when we'll fly up to
me on stage and then I could eat it
right here in front of you but I have
heard a lot of people talk about how
they feel like when their programming
feels like they're doing magic that is
because of the ability for language to
manipulate change and have an effect on
the environment but it's not all pile of
differences there are some similarities
between programming languages and
natural languages because they are both
languages so both classes of language
have both syntax and semantics so syntax
is you know what is like what's the
right way to put words together it's
kind of what you're studying when you're
studying grammar so they both have that
semantics is the study of meaning so
either on a word level or a sentence
level so you know lines of code have
meaning you could say that but there are
even still more differences so natural
languages have their own morphology and
phonology while programming languages
don't because these are related to the
natural evolution of languages so these
languages again are evolving naturally
versus the evolution of programming
languages which is more regulated and
synthetic Tom or follow G is the study
of the building blocks of words those
prefixes and suffixes the Lego like
kernels of word meaning that may or may
not come from other languages such as
Latin or Greek and phonology is the
study of the way that we pronounce words
and the way that they sound and because
a lot of the words that are that are
used in programming languages come from
English if you're going to pronounce a
word if you're gonna pronounce the line
of code out loud it's going to sound
like you're speaking English so
programming languages especially
JavaScript don't have
their own phonology another similarity
is that both programming languages and
natural languages have pragmatics which
is you know what is socially acceptable
or idiomatic within the language these
violations aren't necessarily
ungrammatical per se but they're just
not quite right in programming languages
you you see this in style guides so you
know got your yes Linton JS hint and
stuff so things that come up that aren't
necessarily syntax errors but you might
get warned of by these tools so
something that really affects semantics
and pragmatics is context so human
language is highly context-sensitive
while programming languages are less so
so while the equus crypt spec defines a
context-free grammar for its parser it
immediately goes on to say that this
grammar is not sufficiently powerful to
explain if something is valid equi
script however human language really
depends on context and is cannot at all
be described by a context-free grammar
and human language relies on context so
much because human language is filled
with ambiguity either semantics or
syntactic but we don't really ever
notice this and that's because our
brains are so good at using context to
what's called resolve the ambiguities to
find the right meaning the intended
meaning for the words or the syntax
which was used so in an example of a
syntactically ambiguous sentence is I
saw the unicorn with the binoculars so
this can have two interpretations can
either be that I was using a pair of
binoculars to see a unicorn or that I
see a unicorn who owns her own pair of
binoculars so well I mean I think this
is pretty cool that human language can
do this it would be really dangerous for
JavaScript to have syntactic or any type
of ambiguity because you're really
counting on on the consistency and the
repeatability the deterministic of a
line of code especially if you're going
to like call different functions in
certain areas you kind of wanted to
have the same effect whenever you call
it right so yeah not so great so its
context that allows human language to be
rich it allows us to do cool things with
language it allows us to make puns which
i think is the favorite type of wordplay
in the JavaScript community you also get
meta meaning from context so the way
that you say something affects its
meaning for example sarcasm we know that
everybody loves sarcasm right so uh
human language is messy and it's great
most of the time and javascript is not
that messy and it's also a great most of
the time so one thing that we really
depend on context for is what's called
reference so in human languages these
this comes up as pronouns it's like okay
well yeah it seems like variables could
kind of be a pronoun analog in
programming languages because variables
you define a thing and then you say what
it refers to and then you keep using
that thing that you defined well with
pronouns they refer to something like
otherwise mentioned within a context and
in human languages there's two types of
reference one is called an afro and the
other is called Khafre so in a nephron
seeeeee the thing that you're referring
to comes up before the pronouns so you
see Jenna and talk before she and it in
Katara the pronouns occur before the
things that they're referring to so you
have she and there before Jenna and
Berlin well this is fine for humans
javascript is not super cool with this
right so much so that there's valuable
hoisting that will theoretically fix the
Katara should it occur so it's not in me
and the final parse product or whatever
I saw another form of reference in in
JavaScript that was not really just like
distinguished in human language which
was JavaScript's this
so for JavaScript the reference is kind
of implicit you never really officially
define what this is it's just part of
the way the JavaScript works and it's
based on the context and JavaScript
always has this down even if us as
humans reading a program might not have
it completely down you might not know
what this is all the time if you're
reading code um and then if all else
fails JavaScript we'll just all else
fails JavaScript will just say it's in
the it's refers to the global scope
imagine if someone used to pronoun and
you didn't know what it was and you just
figured it referred to the whole world
that would be kind of weird um um
because we don't need this default
because we are capable of following up
and asking what things mean so um we're
much better at error handling so that's
I humans don't make syntax errors like
there's dangling pronouns everywhere but
um it's you know we can say oh like who
did you mean by she and then they'll be
like oh i meant Janice or you didn't
catch that while if this happens
JavaScript would just throw a syntax
error and it wouldn't be that great so
moving on um because we as humans use
language to represent things and
javascript is a language it makes sense
that both human language and JavaScript
deal in this field of concepts and
categories this is also known as
knowledge representation and it is
essential for humans abilities to parse
but then deal with the world and
interact with things if we were to have
a unique way of dealing with every
single object in the world we would fall
over kind of like JavaScript does
encounters a syntax error so we put
things into buckets so we know how to
deal with things generally and this is
how we effectively and efficiently deal
with the world so this is this is called
cognitive economy so an example of what
we might use concepts and categories for
is identifying that this yorkie puppy is
a dog and not a cat uh you know this it
could possibly be a cat right it has
some cat-like
features pointy ears it's very kind of
the size of cat four legs and if it
never makes a sound you don't know that
it works but we know it's dog
automatically there's no problem with
that so for humans a lot of this
concepts and categories stuff is about
object recognition so how do we
recognize and then deal with objects but
again javascript doesn't perceive
because it's a programming language so
like I was like there's got to be
something in here like let me just keep
looking for him right notes so as I was
looking through my cognitive science
notes some words kind of stood out at me
so I was looking at the categorization
theories and there's classical and
prototype theory and then like that
looks familiar as compared to
inheritance architectures um it might
actually be a coincidence these the
words themselves but what is not a
coincidence is that the overall theories
are actually similar this the classical
theory of categorization is very similar
to object inheritance in JavaScript and
some other programming languages this is
because one of the authors one of the
the theorists for this first
categorization theory uh was before he
was working on this cognitive science
stuff he was thinking about how to
organize information within computer
programs he realized that it was most
economical for computers to use
well-ordered hierarchies and then he was
like huh yeah I wonder if this applies
to humans too let's run some experiments
so he and his partner in science came up
with this semantic Network bat which two
test subjects so in this you see
categories are organized in a
hierarchical structure and there's
feature inheritance so to test this they
presented subjects with yes or no
questions and then measured their
reaction time to try and model this
chart in time so they asked those
questions about the pure hierarchy such
as is a canary-bird and is a canary and
animal they also asked questions
about future inheritance so is a canary
yellow and does a canary breathe they
found that true to the chart it took
longer to answer questions that involve
traversing this hierarchy more so it
took longer to answer does a canary
breathe versus is a canary yellow
because yellow is a property on canary
for breathing is a property on animal so
for the most part the subjects had
reaction times that pretty much modeled
this chart and I'm pretty sure that if
we ran JavaScript through the experiment
it would perform like a human because
method dispatch kind of looks like this
but there's starts to break down a
little bit in humans so there's things
called typicality effects so for example
sharks aren't really typical fish so you
know sometimes this gets a little fishy
pun call back so it might take longer
for you to verify that a shark is a fish
then it would be to verify that a shark
is an animal this doesn't really follow
that hierarchy right so theorists are
like all right well we got to reevaluate
this and they came up with some new
theories these are more about similarity
than about hierarchy but it's okay
because we're talking about humans and
not about programming languages and so
this I couldn't really find many
similarities in here between this end
and JavaScript except that it seems like
prototype theories kind of more like
classical inheritance an exempt our
theories kind of for like prototype will
inheritance but that's cool whatever I
did learn and I did get out of this that
maybe object orientation is in fact a
good way to structure your programs but
I'm gonna move on before I get rotten
tomatoes sworn at me okay so another
subset of study within basic within
concepts and categories is this idea of
basic level categories so this is a
natural level of categorization it's
what we tend to use in
versation to this just right level of
specificity that is usually the
pragmatic choice so if we go back to our
trusty hierarchy chart a bird and fish
would be the basic level categories in
here while animal is the superordinate
category and canary and ostrich would be
these subordinates Atta Gauri's so i was
like huh yeah I kind of see this coming
up in JavaScript to my human brain kind
of thinks that like function and number
these are kind of basic level categories
in in JavaScript so I went back to the
trustee ECMO script spec and lo and
behold I found a list of things that I
saw ha yeah this could be javascripts
basic level categories and I ran them
through and like ok so if they're gonna
be basic level categories well first
object is totally the superordinate
category it's the the top of the chart
so if they're going to be basically at
agura's they're going to have object
like clothes as their prototypes so did
this and then I did that and felt really
silly because of course this is what
happened um but I was like there's
something missing here right like I
thought function like my human brain was
thinking that functions were a basic
level and what about arrays and even
date and promise um so I read the spec a
little more and found them in a list
that also included all the
aforementioned things the previous list
and this list was well known intrinsic
objects so these are things that are
explicitly referenced by algorithms of
this specification and I did more
science on these and some of these make
sense uh I wouldn't argue like but other
ones so like array is in here but also
float32 array and my human brain is like
well for raised in there float32 array
is not a basic level but um javascript
is a programming language doesn't have
to think like a human so if it wants to
have a
level category system than a human would
that's cool uh so thus far we've been
focusing on language and representation
but what happens if we think of the
JavaScript runtime as a mind and compare
from that angle so there are a bunch of
metaphors that cognitive scientists will
use to explain attention so one of them
is attention as a filter so you know
your attentional system is going to put
everything through like a sieve and only
the important stuff is going to fall out
and that's what you're going to pay
attention to another metaphor is
attention as a spotlight so the
important stuff is highlighted and
everything else falls to the wayside so
you only pay attention to the stuff that
is under a spotlight there's another
metaphor which is attention is glue
which is a little into the weeds of
cognitive science so there's some
theorists that think that when we
perceive we perceive these like object
features and then its attention that
binds them together into a discrete
object and then lastly there is another
metaphor of attention as control so this
control is blocking out unwanted
distractions and automatic processes so
an example of how attention works as
executive control is this thing called
the Stroop task which you might have
seen in those email chains of your I
serve with this you're supposed to say
the color that the word is written in
and not read the word itself but this is
really hard because reading has become
an automatic process for us as we get
older so it's really hard to not read
the word and to say the color instead so
um none of these really applied to
JavaScript because they're about a 10
about perception and JavaScript again
doesn't perceive because it's a
programming language and JavaScript also
doesn't have automatic processes like we
have like for example reading I was like
well there's gotta be something here and
then
I remember this kind of back-channel
metaphor which is attention as threads
all right so we kind of think about
threads at least I do as multitasking
but yeah so we can extrapolate and use
this metaphor of attention as threads
but humans are really bad at
multitasking um there's a bunch of
studies that have shown this one of them
is an inattentional blindness study so
I'm just remembering this particular
video that they showed me in my
cognitive science class I'm not going to
spoil it in case you want to go and
watch it on YouTube but the premise is
that they tell you to you know count the
number there's two teams passing the
ball back and forth and you're supposed
to count the number of times that only
one team catches the ball I think it's
the White team and if you actually focus
on the task I guess watch the video if
you want but the thing is it proves that
you're really bad at paying attention to
things or noticing things you're not
actually paying attention to so you
can't really multitask there's another
study which is called the dichotic
listening task in which your subjects
were presented with two speech streams
one in one year and one in the other and
they're supposed to only pay attention
to one and maybe do a task such as
saying take back the words that were
spoken in one year so to make sure that
you're actually paying attention to only
that but and then they were asked
questions about the other speech dream
and the other ear and they they're
remembered very very little whether it
was like gibberish they didn't even
notice that there's no semantic
information that goes through my
favorite was one of the studies
presented they spoke check in an
American accent to American subjects and
they didn't even realize that it wasn't
English there's like oh yeah everything
was good I just don't remember what what
the actual content was so you could be
really only can focus on one thing but
there's some light from some experiments
about exactly what's going on with our
inability to multitask
so they found that if you're presented
with two simultaneous activities but in
different modalities so for example
linguistic versus visual so words and
pictures you've more of a chance of
remembering both things are being able
to attend to both things so if you're
supposed to shadow or repeat back words
subjects are able to recall information
presented in pictures better than they
were able to remember information
presented in printed words and then they
were still really bad at remembering any
information spoken to them while doing a
shadowing task so this brings to brings
up this idea of task specific resources
or multiple capacity theory that it's
really enough that we can't multi tasks
that we can't do too many we have us
we've came to too many tasks with Jin
within one like modality silo so you
can't do too many things at once that
involve words you can't do too many
things that involve visual tasks so it's
just all about balancing all that if you
really want a multi task JavaScript just
can't it's just good can't multitask at
all right because it's it's single
threaded so if we're actually talking
about the JavaScript runtime and
thinking about the event loop as
attention javascript will only do one
thing for you at once but javascript is
asynchronous it's really just calling
out to other api's and if we're just
talking about javascript those dumb
browser Steve API is even web workers
don't really count so JavaScript only
has one capacity being JavaScript all
right so I had a relief uh I really
enjoyed going through and comparing
JavaScript to human cognition I've never
ever thought I would read the akwa
scripts back but I did or at least parts
of it and um I learned some new things
about human cognition too even though it
was my major in University uh so um I
hope that you are in some things too and
that you can use it to better your
JavaScript skills um thanks for
listening I will tweet the slides feel
free to
tweet questions at me too or sing my
praises or whatever alright thanks again
I reject